salut salut
[Musique]
yo yo
Salut
chaque
déchets plastiques pour les résidents maintenant
ça vaut le coup
pour l'économie ça aide
économie pour acheter du riz
car ces déchets plastiques peuvent
échange contre du riz
salut salut
[Musique]
Salut
à cause de l'état du café la fin
l'économie est en baisse, oui les gens ont
difficulté à répondre aux besoins
Le principal était le besoin fondamental de manger plus tôt
maison de campagne
salut salut
Salut
[Musique]
il y a 200 villages et nous avons collecté
près de 600 tonnes de déchets plastiques dans la vie
40 000 IDR par famille en un an
Et c'est vraiment très
la communauté a très bien répondu
Salut
[Musique]
rejoindre le programme de Bali, c'est définitivement agir à savoir
séparer les déchets plastiques avec du riz
donc demande Nous sommes plus actifs et
se soucier de l'environnement, en particulier avec
la nature environnante pour ne pas être endommagé par
Déchets plastiques
salut salut
[Musique]